um so here's what i see
i'm not a professional political
scientist so you can take it for what
it's worth
they're buying black votes by waving a
bloody shirt of racism
that's what they're doing they're
selling this idea that george floyd's
death was yet one of another of another
of another
racist state killing of black people
there's open season as ben krupp says in
the title of his book
on black people not black people be
afraid be afraid be very afraid
white racists are coming to get you
they're in your police department
they're right around the corner and we
are the only thing between you
and a noose around your neck that's what
they're saying it's not the new
the georgia voting integrity law is not
just jim crow it's jim
eagle they they want to put you all in
chains that's a quote from
president joseph button they want to put
y'all back in chains
okay so if black people i speak now to
african americans if you happen to be
watching the dave
dave rubin report if you fall for this
we're fools if we fall for this
we are fools we're being led around with
a ring
through our noses
all right so let's move on to some of
the other things well first off
according to my paperwork here you're
black is that
is that time i checked i was like i was
born in chicago 1948
on the south side my mother and father
were also born in chicago
and they were black i'm black okay so as
a black man that's a professor at a
liberal university i unfortunately end
up having to ask
all of my my black guests or i would
rather say guests who happen to be black
that are doing something sort of similar
to what you're doing
can you just talk a little bit about the
type of treatment you get not from some
of the good students but just sort of
you know from the say anti-racist crowd
because
they're not that thrilled with you
i you know i'm probably the wrong guy to
ask i mean i'm 72 years old
okay i know it doesn't show but it's
true born in 1948
so i'm a i'm a senior member of the
community i've been around for a long
time i'm a known quantity
uh i you know i have the various
accolades that i have i've had a
distinguished career as a research
economist
i don't think people really tell me
what they think or react to me
it may be certain deference to my
position into my senior
status it may be out of respect for my
for my
academic accomplishments i hold a chair
here at brown et cetera
um i think they make whisper uh
out of my earshot this or that but but i
don't feel the chill
now kofi kovid has had an impact here
because we're not coming face to face
we're meeting through zoom and skype and
such
and this last year has been a year in
which some of my
more conservative uh ideas especially
about race and
diversity and equity have come to a head
because of the
reckoning about race in the aftermath of
george floyd and all of that
i've written pieces that have gotten a
lot of positive play in
conservative quarters which i'm sure
some of my colleagues despise
but i'm not seeing them around the lunch
table at the faculty club so that they
can
you know convey their contempt for me
with their glare or their whatever
so i so i i don't know about the last
year
but before that i would say it was kind
of like a gentleman's agreement
they you know glenn's glenn is a
curmudgeon
glenn is glenn yeah that's where he's
coming from
he's not a bad guy he's all screwed up
about this stuff but that's all right
we'll still invite him to dinner you
know
and i don't know what's going to happen
once we get back to uh business as usual
we'll see
it's kind of funny idea for a short
story a conservative professor who
because of lockdowns can feel more
emboldened because the colleagues aren't
going to
sneer at him at the commissary or
something you know
somebody ought to be working on that
story somebody should be
do you sense there's anything left i
mean i get you're not a democrat i
haven't heard you say you're a
republican but i get you're not a
democrat
i'm a registered independent who's you
know playing both sides of the street so
to speak but i'm not very happy with
where the democrats are right yeah i
mean do you sen is there anything
left there that is in line with the
ideas that you believe in that you think
is in line with the ideas of martin
luther king the democrats are nothing
without the black voting 95
90 for their candidates they would lose
control of everything without the sub
fine would be present today with if
james clyburn were not able to corral
enough black votes in south carolina's
democratic primary
to get him out of the hole um so
here's what i see i'm not a professional
political scientist so you can take it
for what it's worth
they're buying black votes by waving a
bloody shirt of racism
that's what they're doing they're
selling this idea
that george floyd's death was yet one of
another of another of another
racist state killing of black people
there's open season as ben krupp says in
the title of his book
on black people not black people be
afraid be afraid be very afraid
white racists are coming to get you
they're in your police department
they're right around the corner and we
are the only thing between you
and a noose around your neck that's what
they're saying it's not the new
the georgia voting integrity law is not
just jim crow it's jim eagle
they want to put you all in chains
that's a quote from
president joseph button they want to put
y'all back in chains
okay so if black people i speak now to
african americans if you happen to be
watching the dave
dave rubin report if you fall for this
we're fools if we fall for this
we are fools we're being led around with
a ring
through our noses
so uh they show nothing but contempt for
black people
i'm talking about joseph r biden now
i'm with you i know my audience is with
you and i think
i think actually truly i think most of
america is with you we
we just don't know where the brave
voices are i think that's part of the
problem i mean you're one of them but i
think that
we're living in this in this bravery
deficit right now
these issues the racial conflict coming
out of slavery
threaten the existence of the republic
600
000 people in the country of 30 million
were slaughtered on the battlefields of
the civil war
the consequence of which was the
emancipation of the african slaves
here we are now 150 years later and the
descendants of those slaves
are citizens of the freest richest and
most powerful republic
in the history of the world man glenn
you want to run for president i got it
you're 72 but come on
come on that's young for a president
these days
thanks i appreciate that uh that's
that's
not the burden i was thinking about
taking up right now i was looking for
the beach i was looking to put my feet
up man
fair enough fair enough um well can you
can you paint away or do you see a way
out of this i think a lot of people sort
of think we're just
we're just in this endless descent we
can we can address the things that
you've addressed we could say no you
guys are wrong because we have to talk
about
disparities instead of discrimination we
have to define things properly
but i think a lot of people think oh we
we just can't stop
this force
i don't know how it stops to be honest
with you i feel like i'm spitting in the
wind
my my little humble efforts with john
mcwhorter we have a podcast the glenn
show and we talk about these things and
whatnot
that's at patreon.com forward slash
glenn show two ends one word
uh you know we'll link to it but i gotta
get you on locals that's a different
topic
oh okay but but in any case man i i i
think
we had a chance with the presidency of
barack obama
to really change the conversation and
that he let us down
uh you we can talk about the presidency
of barack obama it is many many things
it's not just this but on this portfolio
if i had a son he looked like trayvon he
shouldn't have said that
should have said my friend against the
police act that stupidly we could go
through all these things
he shouldn't have made al sharpton uh
200 times visiting the white house
ambassador to black america
from his administration he shouldn't
have done that he should have stood for
law and order when baltimore was burning
down when ferguson missouri was burning
down instead of splitting the difference
and saying
they have legitimate grievances of
course they have legitimate grievances
but it doesn't rise to the level of
arson
and assault on police officers and
looting that's unforgivable that's
that cannot be tolerated i don't care
what their grievances are and he should
have said so
he should have turned to black america
as he tried to do a little bit during
the campaign but he
beat a retreat from it and said yeah
there's racism but you know what we need
to pull up our socks
he could have found a better way of
saying it he could have found an obama
ass
way of saying it we need to stand up
straight with our shoulders back as
jordan peterson
could say we need to take care of our
kids we need to get busy
racism is not the first or the second or
the third issue
confronting us he could have said that
he could have shut up
some of these people like tomahasico
instead he invites them for cozy talks
uh etc shut him up by saying
my occupying this office
commander-in-chief of the most powerful
military on the planet
the agenda center for this great
republic of 325 million people
gives the lie to your talk about uh
oppressive denial of the integrity of
black bodies
he said it in 2004 barack obama did he
said it's in my very dna
he's black and he's white we all are
metaphorically speaking there's only one
people
here the american people there's only
one people
here uh for a variety of reasons
president obama
elected and it's not an easy job it's a
hard job that's why i don't want it
thanks anyway
i apologize i apologize for a variety of
reasons he elected
not to take that one on and he's the
only person who
could have taken it on he's the only
person who could have sat in the white
house
you saw what happened when trump tried
to order out the national guard or
whatever it was he tried to do to deal
you know and everybody goes ballistic
and it's all
racist and whatnot like obama is the
only person who could have changed that
conversation
by putting his racial identity and his
civic responsibility on the line
not as a fealty to the black victim
narrative
but as an affirmation of the
possibilities of the country
now it's easy for me to say this i know
but that's what i
see when i look at it in retrospect and
opportunity was missed between 2009
and 2017 uh and where we are now
i mean i heard michelle obama the former
first lady
say to gail king at cbs morning news the
other day
that she worried that her daughter sasha
and malia might be set upon by
wrong police officers because they're
black and they might be mistaken for
somebody
and i have to to that i have to say this
i mean i said this in my pockets i'll
say it to you
first of all it's false it's false you
got to get past the secret service to
get to those kids
she knows its fault secondly she knows
that what she said
is untrue so what is she doing she's
playing you negroes
she's playing you she's enacting
a trope a narrative on
in the surface of a political program
which is to keep you on the reservation
afraid that the boogeyman racist is
gonna come and get your children
she's not worried about her children
being harassed by on martha's vineyard
by a a cop because they're black
so instead of pushing
against this narrative which is
comforting
it is a comfortable place to be if
you're black i'm a victim
they wouldn't let me get the nobel prize
because i was black i'm an economist i'm
a damn good economist
i want the nobel prize i want the nobel
prize they wouldn't let me have it
because i'm playing
okay that is getting old
but we need our leaders i'm talking
about african-american leaders
to point a way for a point away from
that and
they're not doing it if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell